first things first the press conference
uh president biden put out some major
major sanctions on all russian banks
every one of them uh trillion that over
a trillion dollars of assets every
russian
businesses that are linked to u.s
anything from russia that's doing
business in the u.s all the accounts
have frozen here
the market in russia tanked
45 just yesterday that's nearly a
quarter of a billion dollars the market
lost in a day uh gas prices are going up
because a lot of the world we're not
pumping our own gas right now we're not
fracking as much as we could we're
relying on other places this is why
you're seeing gas prices going up even
though president biden is saying he
doesn't want the gas companies and oil
companies to exploit this opportunity
it's not about that gas prices are going
to go up these
people that are running small gas
stations it's a small business owner
it's not like they're billionaires
millionaires they're just trying to make
eight cents on a dollar they're making
you know whatever the numbers is but the
markets felt it uh in russia videos are
being shown
with people that are protesting outside
and russian police is coming immediately
arresting these guys and some of the
places they can't even get in because
there's so many people out there saying
stop this whole mess we don't need to be
doing this
it's not looking pretty but putin's
planned this for quite some time uh i've
been saying gas prices are about to go
to 10 in california for a while it's
gonna get there it's already at six
dollars we have a bunch of people here
with us
that are from california talking about
how they're feeling immediate gas prices
as of yesterday on top of that for quite
like a while
weeks maybe a couple months russia's
been
right around the border and everybody's
saying what are you doing nato just had
a meeting at geneva saying hey why are
you over here oh nothing it's just
regular training you can do it you're
pretty big you can do your training
everywhere anywhere why are you doing
your training right on the border and
you're building hospitals and you're
moving a hundred thousand troops all of
a sudden 125 000 troops and 150 000
troops and now over 175 000 troops blood
they got everything prepared that in
case something were to happen you know
move blood supplies hospitals
everybody's ready for that i think
russian air force one of the units the
airborne unit took over a small airport
that's right by kiev because they have a
whole strategy on what they want to do
with the capital
they know they don't have a lot of time
it's not like this is gonna be a
six-month war or a three-month war they
have a small
window that putin's trying to capitalize
and we're going to see whether this is
going to be taking place or not over 40
people have already been killed one
ukrainian plate was shot down with five
people that were killed this just
happened
and uh you know for some people that are
wondering like who is ukraine you know
what is the big deal with ukraine why is
ukraine so important is it that
important of a country i'm in u.s
i'm in texas i thought texas was big i
thought new york was big why is
everybody you know going crazy over
ukraine what supplies does ukraine have
so there's a couple different arguments
here one of the arguments is
the fact that you know uh this is
putin's ex because putin wrote about
this how when soviet union fell in 1991
and when it collapsed
at that time you know ukraine became its
own country russia became its own
country
and you know this is during cold war and
uh ukraine became independent and at
that time when ukraine became
independent people have to realize
ukraine inherited most of soviet union's
nuclear power this is what a lot of
people don't know they inherited most of
the nuclear power let me give you some
stats so you know how much this was 176
inter-count intercontinental ballistic
missiles
1249 numeral warheads 44 strategic
bombers 700 nuclear-tipped cruise
missiles 2 000 tactical weapons all of
this went to ukraine and ukraine at the
time
the the leader that they had wasn't
somebody that you know he was a he was a
pretty strong personality himself
and uh russia comes in and negotiates in
they gave all those weapons up to russia
so think about this majority of those
weapons were given up to russia in
exchange for negotiation russia promised
them guaranteed security we're never
going to mess with you we're going to
respect ukraine's sovereignty all this
stuff is going on right now while this
is taking place a few things happen we
they signed the budapest agreement let's
kind of try to make this work let's be
peaceful let's not make anything happen
the original signers i think was u.s uk
i want to say belarus and you know
kazakhstan so they signed it let's make
this work right afterwards in around
the leader of
ukraine was victor yanukovych okay who
was a puppet to uh putin and he was more
pro-russia than pro-ukraine which kind
of helped out he was a corrupt guy
heavy-handed pro-moscow and during that
time while this has taken place
2013 he the leader rejected an eu deal
so the eu comes in and says hey let's
make this work let's kind of come
together come join nato come join eu
we're gonna give you an offer he
rejected the deal but took 15 billion
dollar bailout from russia putin okay so
this is a guy that was you know for
russia even though he's running ukraine
anyways eventually he's replaced by the
current pm the current president he
leaves he goes to russia some people
didn't want him to leave some people
wanted him to leave so that's one part
of the argument that to putin was like
ukraine's been part of soviet union for
the longest time there's no way i'm
going to give up my ex there's no way
i'm going to let my ex go marry somebody
else and if he my ex she marries nato or
she marries eu there's no way i'm going
to let that happen so putin's made some
demands to uh nato and here's his
demands you ready crazy demands by the
way number one his demand was
for nato to stop expanding that's the
number one demand number two i believe
they're up to 30 countries right now
eastern europe which is just not gonna
happen withdraw from all troops from
eastern europe and number three for
america to vow
not to protect their allies with nuclear
weapons for america to vow not to
protect their eastern european allies
with weapons right
where they are so all of this stuff he's
asking so he wants them to come back he
wants to move quickly in kiev he wants
to replace with a new leader but this is
the one part most people also don't
realize what ukraine has let me give you
some of the rankings of what ukraine has
in regards to size there's six hundred
and four thousand square kilometer
kilometers so it's pretty good size i
think it's 44 million in population and
i want to say their gross domestic
produce i think their gdp is around a
quarter of a billion dollars where 156
billion dollars is their gdp that's
where they are 156 good size population
44 million relatively good size
[Music]